what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and we have really
really big news today breaking news for
those of you who may be like me and have
been waiting for marvel studios to
finally make a thunderbolts movie it
looks like this wait is over and the
movie is finally being made but get this
according to recent reports this movie
might be like the suicide squad and that
begs the question since marvel has kind
of been going down a little bit more of
a darker path lately with multiverse of
madness and moon knight the question is
this going to be rated r some fans might
prefer that some fans might not but
we're gonna talk about everything that
we know so far about the thunderbolts in
the mcu go over this report that states
that this movie is finally in
development and talk about who the
members of the thunderbolts could be so
let's dive into it and of course if
you're new and you love marvel be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest news and videos so for
those who want to know at what stage of
development the thunderbolts movie is in
one yes it is official and two it's so
official that they have the director
already for the upcoming project and for
those wondering if this was going to be
a movie or disney plush show we have our
answer it is going to be a movie this is
coming directly from deadline.com and
the title for the article literally
reads marvel's thunderbolts movie tabs
jake schreier as director and i probably
said that name wrong i apologize so it's
official we have our thunderbolts movie
coming to the mcu it is officially in
development and they have a director but
guess what they also have a writer for
the project already as well and this one
might be a little bit controversial to
some people because the deadline article
reads marvel studios's top secret
thunderbolts movie looks to have gained
momentum as deadline has learned that
jake schreier is set as a director of
the new marvel temple and then it says
black widow scribe eric pearson is
pinning the script with marvel studios
president kevin feige producing now i
already tweeted this out on twitter and
put it out on instagram and if you're
not following me you should be but
people are already commenting that the
black widow writer is not a good thing
because some people didn't like black
widow but a lot of people really did
like black widow and you have to keep in
mind that this is an entirely different
movie and the pandemic is not really
going to affect this movie whereas black
widow seriously got affected by the
pandemic so let's keep an open mind
kevin foggy of course is producing and
so far what we know about the
thunderbolts is pretty dang good all of
the characters that have been set up in
the mcu to be a part of the team are
awesome and this article actually
provides us with a little bit more
detail so let's continue to read it says
not much is known about the plot of the
film other than it revolving around a
group of super villains or at least
characters who have played bad guys at
one point in the mcu who go on missions
for the government the other element
that is vague is which characters will
be a part of this team since its film is
technically still in development though
sources say marvel has been in touch
with certain individuals who are already
part of the mcu to make sure that they
keep an opening in their schedules for
next summer when it shoots so we are
actually getting this movie sooner
rather than later because it is about to
shoot next summer so we are getting this
movie within the next two years and
that's good because there's a little bit
more setup the mcu has to do for the
full thunderbolts team but let's
continue to read it says that said some
of the characters that could potentially
be starring or making some sort of
appearance are baron zemo yelena balova
taskmaster the abomination u.s agent and
winter soldier and we'll talk about that
lineup in just a bit but i think it's
important to note that one of the final
paragraphs of this article says while
the town has been buzzing about the
fantastic four directing search which
has only begun meeting potential
candidates the studio has been quietly
focused on thunderbolts and according to
insiders schreier's presentation in
recent weeks blew away execs and
ultimately landed him the job so that is
extremely good news the presentation for
the thunderbolts blew away the marvel
studios executives this is a big deal
this is an entirely new team this isn't
a one character disney plush show a one
character or a couple of characters
movie this is a full team this is
basically a new avengers team except
they're pretty much the dark avengers
it's been rumored for some time now that
the dark avengers and the thunderbolts
were kind of going to be thrown into one
team and if that is the case it
definitely looks like their name is
going to be the thunderbolts now the
thunderbolts in the comics are named
after thaddeus thunderbolt ross we of
course have seen thunderbolt ross in
recent mcu films black widow being one
of them now sadly the actor that played
thunderbolt ross william hurt has passed
away he passed away of march this year
so it might be a little up in the air if
thunderbolt ross is going to be the
person who brings this team together
especially if you consider the fact that
they do have valentina allegra de
fontaine out there recruiting for we
assume the thunderbolts now valentina
first appeared in the falcon and the
winter soldier she recruited john walker
and she actually gave him his new title
of us agent from there we assumed that
she was forming some type of dark team
presumably the thunderbolts we then saw
her again in the post-credits scene for
black widow where we saw her talking to
yelena balova and in this post-credits
scene yelena was already working for her
and then of course she gave her the
folder of hawkeye told her that hawkeye
is the one responsible for the death of
natasha and sent yelena to go kill him
so if valentina is the one putting
together the thunderbolts which it
really does seem like that it's not
going to be all good because technically
valentina has already tried to get
hawkeye killed and we know of course
hawkeye is a great guy he has been
defending the planet for a very long
time now he's an original avenger and
valentina tried to get yelena to kill
him but that's why they're the
thunderbolts they're going to be doing
the dirty work which is one of the most
exciting things about this group they're
kind of the opposite of the avengers and
here's where things get really exciting
for me in this article they state the
film is technically still in development
so no talent have closed deals yet but
marvel sees this as their version of the
suicide squad and some characters you
could probably expect on the team
include yelena bulova task master us
agent and zemo among others now zemo
already had connections to valentina so
i am assuming that she is going to be a
part of the grip yelena technically
already kind of is a part of the group
and u.s agent we saw him get recruited
now since taskmaster went with the other
black widows at the end of black widow i
am kind of assuming that she probably
works for valentina as well which makes
it pretty easy for taskmaster to join
the thunderbolts the only question i
have right now about who's going to be
on the team is whether or not they're
going to put red hulk on the team red
hulk in the comics of course is
thunderbolt ross and like i just
mentioned william hurt has recently died
now of course there are options they
could recast the character or they could
simply use cgi after all they did kind
of view cgi and black widow on william
hurt plus when red hulk is in red hulk
form that's gonna be mocap anyways mark
ruffalo isn't actually the hulk so red
hulk can be done using technology no
problem whatsoever the only question is
are they going to keep thunderbolt ross
around and will he be a part of the team
as red hulk and i'm inclined to say yes
since deadline is saying that this is a
thunderbolts movie so if it's titled
thunderbolts i'm going to go ahead and
say that it's titled after thunderbolt
ross forming the group and sidenote i
still think valentino works for him just
kind of you know secretly on the side to
do his dirty work but this is extremely
exciting news we've all been waiting for
an announcement for the thunderbolts
movie we had heard rumors for a while
that it's going to be coming and now we
finally have an official announcement
d23 is coming up very soon perhaps they
will do a whole new reveal of a new
phase of marvel studios and hopefully
they will announce it then but in the
meantime let me know how excited you are
for a thunderbolts movie in the comments
down below and let me know what members
you would like to see on it don't forget
to give the video a like and subscribe
if you're new to the channel and want to
stay up to date on all things marvel and
mcu for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof